under pressure from the far right
speaker Kevin McCarthy launched a formal
impeachment inquiry based on no evidence
I have yet to see something that's
evidence of a crime not a shred of
evidence that President Biden engaged in
wrongdoing is there really no evidence
of President Joe Biden's corruption
hardly Biden's Defenders are right that
there's no definitive Smoking Gun but
recent Revelations about Hunter Biden's
business dealings are absolutely sketchy
and should make us squint at his dad
remember Joe Biden said he had no
involvement in Hunter's business
dealings which include millions of
dollars in payments from the Ukrainian
energy firm barisma from the Chinese
from a Russian billionaire and other
foreign entities but we know Hunter's
real business was leveraging his
relationship with dear old dad Joe Biden
allegedly called his son repeatedly
during business dinners in which Hunters
Associates were present Joe Biden also
attended such dinners twice it's too
soon for impeachment sure but still
seems well worth investigating no